odessa en la costa ucraniana del mar
negro es un objetivo habitual de los
misiles rusos la ciudad portuaria ha
estado en el punto de mira del kremlin
desde que los tanques rusos entraron a
ucrania en febrero esto de ser una
prioridad en esta guerra el presidente
ruso lo ha hecho desde el inicio en
particular la importancia simbólica en
la ciudad en cuanto a sus vínculos con
las históricas ambiciones imperiales de
rusia para quien es un punto de contacto
con el mundo exterior o de esa la
tercera ciudad más grande del país
después de que jarquín es un importante
centro de transporte y envíos que
conecta a ucrania con el resto del mundo
aproximadamente el 65 por ciento de las
importaciones y exportaciones de ucrania
pasan por los tres puertos de la ciudad
eso incluye las exportaciones de trigo
la captura de la ciudad sería una gran
victoria estratégica para moscú que le
permitiría estrangular la economía de
ucrania y dominar la costa del norte del
mar negro o de esa es también la sede de
la marina ucraniana
trasladó su central a la ciudad después
de perder su base naval en crimea en
2014 cuando rusia se anexionó la
península de odesa cae también podría
haber graves consecuencias para los
vecinos de ucrania o desees un corredor
terrestre que une a las fuerzas rusas en
el este con la región extendida de
moldavia y transnistria que busca la
independencia desde la década de los 90
unos 1.500 soldados rusos se encuentran
en la región para mantener la paz y la
captura de la región podría
desestabilizar aún más a moldavia ya los
países cercanos